NIKOLA KAMBUROV: Hi, guys.
Today we're going
to see how one can
use linear algebra to
describe graphs and networks.
In particular, we'll do
the following problem.
We're given this very
simple graph here
with five nodes and six edges.
We've already labeled
them, and we've
put directions on the edges.
And we are asked to write
down the incidence matrix A,
and then to compute its kernel
and the kernel of A transpose.
And finally, we're
asked to compute
the trace of A transpose A.
I'll give you a few moments to
try the problem on your own.
And then you'll
see my take on it.
Hello again.
OK, so let's first recall
what an incidence matrix is.
So an incidence
matrix is supposed
to encode how the nodes
connect to the edges.
In particular, it
has as many rows
as there are edges and as many
columns as there are nodes.
And we're going to
fill in the rows.
And we'll fill them
out as follows.
So we're going to use
only negative 1, 1, and 0.
And we're going to put a
negative 1 in entry i and 1
in entry j if the corresponding
edge connects node i to node j.
OK, let me just
do it concretely.
So let's look at edge number 1.
So it corresponds
to the first row.
It connects 1 to 2.
So we have a negative 1 and a 1.
Then edge number 2, it connects
node 2 to 3, so negative 1, 1.
Edge number 3 connects node
1 to 3, so negative 1, 1.
And I believe you get
the picture, right?
So I'm just going to fill
out the rest of the entries.
All right, 4 is:
negative 1, to 1.
5 is: well, 4, well,
negative 1, 1 here.
And 6 is: negative 1 and 1.
OK.
So we've constructed
the matrix A. Now,
we'll compute its null space.
And we're going to do it
without performing any row
operations whatsoever.
So in order to do this,
it's helpful to look
at the graph as an
electric circuit
and to assign to each of the
nodes an electric potential.
If we collect all the
electric potentials
in a vector x, then A times x
is a vector with as many entries
as there are edges
and gives precisely
the potential differences
across the edges of the graph.
OK, so then if A*x is to be
0, this means that across
the graph, across all
the edges of the graph,
all potential differences are 0.
Therefore, all the
potentials at all the nodes
need to be equal to
a constant number.
So therefore, we conclude
that the null space of A
is spanned by constant 1.
OK?
There are five 1's
here, corresponding
to the five nodes.
Now what about the null
space of A transpose?
Adopt this analogy
with electric circuits.
But this time, we're going
to look at currents flowing
across the edges of the graph.
Oh, and we are going to adopt
the following convention
for the currents.
So a current is
going to be positive
if it flows in the direction
of the edge and negative
if it flows in the
opposite direction.
Right.
So then, what is A
transpose y, where
y is a vector, each of
whose entries is a current
on the edge?
Well, the entries
of A transpose y
are precisely equal to the total
current flowing through each
of the nodes of the graph.
So A transpose y
being equal to 0
means that there is a
balance in the circuit,
that the currents that
flow into each node
equal the currents
that flow out of it.
Right.
And it's fairly easy to
find such a configuration
of currents that satisfies
this balance equation.
We do it by flowing
around loops of the graph.
So you see, this
graph has three loops.
The first one is this
triangle up there.
The second one is this square.
And I'm just, by this
curled direction,
I'm signifying in which way
I'm going to trace the loop.
And there is third
loop, is along
the outer contour of the graph.
But in fact, the
third one can be
thought of as a
superposition of these two,
and I'll explain
why in a second.
So let's figure out the
configuration of currents
that balances these loops.
So if we flow a
current 1 from 1 to 2
and then flow a current of
1 along edge 2, from 2 to 3,
and then we flow a
current of negative 1,
mind that the
direction is opposite
to the direction
of the loop, then
we're going to have a balanced
configuration of currents.
So let me write this down.
The following configuration, so
1 along edge 1, 1 along edge 2,
and negative 1 along
edge 3, and the rest 0,
is a solution to A transpose y.
Let's see what solution
we get by flowing around
the loop in the square.
Well, we flow a current
of 1 along edge 4,
current of 1 along edge 5,
current of 1 along edge 6,
and current of negative
1 along edge 2.
So let's be careful.
So it was 0, then along
edge 2 was negative 1.
Along 3: 0; along 4: 1;
along 5: 1; along 6: 1.
Now we can do the same
thing with the big loop
and produce a vector
corresponding to it.
And I prompt you to do it.
But what you'll see is that
the vector that you get
is precisely a sum
of these two vectors.
In a way, the big loop
is a superposition
of the small loops.
OK, so we figured out what the
null space of A transpose is.
And now, let's
concentrate our attention
on finding the trace
of A transpose A. We're
going to do it right here.
So the trace of a matrix is the
sum of its diagonal entries.
And we've seen this
many times already,
that the diagonal
entries of A transpose A
are precisely the magnitudes
squared of the columns of A.
OK?
So the (1, 1) entry
is the magnitude
squared of the first column.
The (2, 2) entry
is the magnitude
squared of the second
column, and so on.
Now what is the
magnitude squared
of a column of an
incidence matrix?
Well, each entry in a column
of an incidence matrix
is either 1, negative 1, or 0.
So when we square these
entries, we get 1's or 0's.
And when we add them up,
we get precisely a number
which is the nontrivial
entries in that column.
OK?
So the magnitude
squared of the column
is the number of
nontrivial entries in it.
But if we go back
to the matrix A,
and we count the number
of non-zero entries,
this is precisely the number of
edges that connect with a node.
OK, so the number of edges
that connects with each node
is called the
degree of the node.
In this way, trace
of A transpose A
will be just the
sum of the degrees
of the graph in the picture.
So we have there are 2
edges connecting to 1, so 2,
plus 3 edges connecting to
2, 3 edges connecting to 3.
And we've got a 2 for the
number of edges connecting to 4,
and 2 for the number of
edges connecting to 5.
So altogether, we get 12.
So you see, in this problem, we
computed certain linear algebra
objects without performing the
usual algebraic operations,
but just by looking at
the graph and seeing
how the linear algebra
is encoded in it.
I hope it was most illuminating.
I'll see you next time.